you
I've only done a couple fear without cuz
I I put the wrench in cross here pretty
easy to remember haha my usual jelly hey
get off the sidewalk it's usually that
or it's that a Chow time you have to
memorize the whistle the gas extra Mayo
I had I had one where i was in orderly i
was fat orderly where I go you're gonna
be good that was one like you gonna be
good i had to leave you in here that was
like one of those kind of thing um hey
everybody welcome to my dumb friends oh
this is uh I don't know oh we already
started yeah this is mrs. of the podcast
archos aren't ya like the Pete Holmes as
the organic like hey haha hurry hurry
here had I love for Christ verdana
started because Dan gets so in his head
yeah time he starts it anyways I did
that sound natural enough damn doesn't
gender like hard it we talked about this
a lot but he used to started like hey
everybody and then we made fun of each
other for that we both would do that and
then we tried to start it we were just
talking and we started that way and then
now Dan just did a very like hey
everybody that would have been totally
fine and you didn't [ __ ] up but yeah
we're like oh man like well I love in
[ __ ] up yet no nothing [ __ ] oh it
was fine I was like because I did well
well cuz i was doing a podcast with
o'connor last night me goes well now the
hack thing is you the pete holmes thing
where you start the podcast and then
introduce it well i didn't copy that or
the marin thing I guess well here's the
thing it's also it's like well then
gonna run out of options on how to start
a [ __ ] pocket yes darling are you
know how you started to get a [ __ ] oh
well didn't hurt anybody go hey that pot
the rest of it was [ __ ] but that opening
was fantastic nail deal our guest today
is who Dan Kumail Nanjiani hey
we get for the bug ya I'm not juggling
sorry guess we had a have one fuse
credit combined haha I'm excited I'm
gonna wring a weird echo in my
headphones my excuse me oh ok it's a
ghost yeah um i'm just gonna do ya oh
how are you doing man great great great
great thanks for having me guys shows
great the last people we had were it was
just the whole cast of the access comedy
live yes i saw stellar axis of evil yeah
it was a V we said though right what was
that that was like that was a meta med
that was that guy Dean Obeidallah you
have a dollar on who is what it'll use
turns puppets the Middle Eastern but
he's like I don't know I think he's like
half Middle Eastern yes he looks like a
white dude to me doesn't that weird to
say also his first name is Dean yes
which is what a wife and whitest name is
possible yes yeah that's the White House
that great Afghani comic Chad yeah like
I met on med you like oh yeah that makes
complete sense Dean I do like that names
trying a little harder i do or omit
Alicia I read his last me was like
Jackson I don't I i I've no Dean a
little bit and he's very nice and I'm
very nice guy I don't mean to make fun
of anybody well too bad cause deeds on
our shitless this week you try to turn
this into a morning zoo as well yeah
yeah I guess you're right uh I forgot
you have an x-files podcast now yeah
yeah yeah how is it people like it huh I
think so I feel like it I it's I I was
supposed to do this how it started so I
love the Expos I wanted to watch it
again and I knew at the summer off for
silicon valley are supposed to do this
movie now and then the movie felt her
and i was like [ __ ] I have nothing to do
now I'll just watch all of the x-files
and talk about it it's like the sixth
time you've done it too right it's all
the expose this is the fourth whoa my
gone silent I thought I was good i went
through the wire twice yeah and the
sopranos twice good is that the word
you're good or it's sad the word is it
sadder is it I just love the show and I
love watching it again but what have I
started releasing it and it was like
people started listening and then you
can't stop so I basically made another
job for myself I loved it I loved
watching the show and talking about it
but it's like I gotta do like a research
and stuff for every episode you are you
doing at all in the beginning I was
skipping episodes and people would get
angry at me and I was like this [ __ ]
thing didn't exist until a month ago and
you're now you're like angry at it um
right now I do all have people like it I
guess we can get the company on it now I
do all of them uh he's shooting right
now I'm gonna try for the company
obviously I'm gonna try for all of them
I want to wait a little bit guy who
plays Skinner no problem I would love to
get ya be great i got ready pledgee yeah
well the smoking man then he died the
smoking guy no no he's alive he's alive
okay yeah I love that show well we went
to go see the movie together cuz we're
just I'll [ __ ] oh that's right I
forgot you brought the fit he's sewing
what he brought a Mulder and Scully
action be any I think I forget we eat
yeah the figure I'm good it's louie
child a figure do you remember then look
does like you have the traits of someone
who doesn't have a beautiful wife and
isn't successful in your in shape but
you have these traits that the same
people who like who like anyone else I
give anyone would have thought are you
anyone who brings an action figure to a
movie right there's no way he's on an
HBO show I guess I just put shelving in
my house for my action figures did I
don't have that many of I have had me
not that many because i can't imagine
with you it's not in my head it's gonna
be a lot what is a lot to you 20 okay no
I've got I've got like 12 okay all right
that's not too bad that's not good I'm
you know okay yeah i'll kill you have
action figures I have like Hulk Hogan
and somebody else did you see the thing
where they have breaking bad action
figures and then the parent with the
toys r us to get rid of them yeah they
want a nice it well what kids want
Breaking Bad action it's not for kids
ahead yeah it's not for kids it's adults
that are buying it's stupid cuz it's not
exposing kids to a thing because either
the kids have already watched the show
and once the action figures that they're
already [ __ ] yeah right Laura they just
want the action figure in which case
they don't know what it is there's
nothing wrong with just a guy in the
yellow suit yeah if you want to die on a
bum debt you if you were kid who hadn't
seen the show and got those action
figures one of the things gonna happen
they're like any of the action figures
need to go home my bike what's this all
about I want to watch breaking bags and
your parents at any moment you go no no
you can't watch it also I don't think
kids would be into that show I don't
think I love that would never get it
they went over their heads i remember
when i got my midnight cowboy action box
driver playset yeah yeah I had my terms
of endearment action figures what I got
my Caligula beanie baby excited about
what was that I'll tell you what action
figures i have okay I got a Batman okay
I've got a Mulder and Scully okay I got
a Hellboy I could have that yeah I got a
another the fluke fluke man from X Files
someone gave me that as a gift oh yeah
when was the food with the flute man
again he's the guy who lives in the
sewer oh yeah I'm kind of emotion is the
name of the episode great episode um I
got Kratos from God God of War I'd which
is a yeah other than the video game yeah
their game um Emily's got a devo action
figure so you could see the Dubrow the
band yeah the types that I guess that I
have yeah yeah I cool Lucy kurzer ironic
i was an ironic heart that's cool she's
leave oh yeah yeah it's cool but it's
like it's ironic this one don't yeah
purchase yes oh yeah right right right
sure what you mean Kratos d Gardevoir
Andrews our regular action figures these
are ones that like you would play with
like they're not the statue at like
standard ones that are like ceramic
really I don't have any of those big
ones as ones I've stared it like ones
that are over a hundred bucks like I
stared at them I've never bottomed but
like they're all I got a couple I got a
few Ninja Turtles actually figured that
cool I got a he-man the original old
he-man um yeah that one the one with the
spin grease pencil yeah yeah
back in the day he man yeah the original
bike and I don't have he man actually
yeah I have a different character from
nice man i used my favorite one was
beast member orange the already had a
smell no no he didn't you're right wass
man had the snow beast man was like
Skeletor is like main guy yeah the
orange guy yeah he was awesome I mean
they had the guy they chose to phase or
whoa who's the guy would switch faces
you could switch faces and time man he
faces man that's what it is that those
as clever as he man man II faces the
thing is it doesn't sound like a name
like what would Batman II Edward nygma
enigma Riddler that's it Edward nygma
it's still a name yeah man he faces also
like it made sense with Batman because
they already had electricity and then
they have like a and mastered
electricity during he-man times no but
they had puns before that do you know
they can't call a man who faces if they
don't want to be like Mexican or
something many many faces man any faces
great play that end off your car man
they did have electricity did cars and
stuff it was in a weird universe with
this magic and also a different planet
wasn't it yes it is a tourney er guys it
was a white that there's a final better
care 10 remember that then the [ __ ]
been in the movie and he's not in the
series well door will doors the best
care why is it not just Orko or goes
great I'm some norco action figure was
it can I have no idea is it that'll cat
was lazy who was it who played yep
grilled or I don't want to say it was uh
Willow was it well I think it's will I
see super the movie you're saying yeah
wait who is Gilda work gweld or was this
character that was basically Orko but
he's a little guy and he's the one who
opens the portal to earth because in
that in that movie because they couldn't
have a huge budget they're like all come
to earth and I um yeah oh right right
right like Bill and Ted's Excellent
Adventure don't think I'm talena
modern-day earth or something yeah I
just watched an episode of Doctor Who
and they always do that where there are
some other planet and the like this is
weird gravity's just normal
and then they just go on with the
episode yeah yeah I don't think they
even addressing me me don't remember
while doing I don't remember the movie I
didn't remember the toys hi Joe and the
cartoon is Skeletor yeah yeah yeah they
[ __ ] wasn't it look right that movie
bombed right it wasn't due any time all
of these movies come out a little bit
later right I make sure a zizou refi to
do that Schreiber demanded that I take
tm2 Ninja Turtles hit at the right time
that's all right at the right time and
they had a couple of them right at the
right time yeah again there's always
like one actor in it who's really like
oh oh uh what's it go i Leah cat is or
whatever the coyote is I've been
arrested yeah he went from a damn orgy
was in uh he was in some kind of
wonderful then he was in that yeah he
was great he's awesome he's really gonna
do April was I was kind of April changed
April only was the second one her name
was paige turco yeah the actress and the
first one [ __ ] her name was um I think
it's a girl from tough guys you meet you
guys remember that movie you don't
matter up guys do you do you ever top
guys that's before you got here maybe I
don't know Tony 80s I sauce ahead Burt
Lancaster and and incur Douglas about
two guys who get seems like it was
unlocked before I got on this earth you
talking about America oh yeah you read
my grandpa's favor the war that was I
kind of think that my dad took me to see
it so bad ya know it was like it was in
the 80s and there was about them
assimilating getting out of jail and
simulating like 80 the 80s that's
exactly what I thought it was gonna be
yeah so it was that's a pretty good
premise yeah I oh good i will reason I
brought of x files to its cuz I remember
when we were watching it you're a big
fan you should do the podcast I would
love to do the podcast but during during
the movie it got like you and me and
Emily both of the thing we were like
yeah I think this could be good its rich
bad the movies bad alright maybe this is
good maybe this is good and then by the
very end of it I don't think that was
good and then there's a post-credit
sequence which then you realize like oh
this was terrible the whole time I was
the kindest Mulder and Scully on on a
speedboat not going through I think the
Caribbean what was it the road and then
look up at the camera in the way
there I guess you were wrong to like
this the whole time it's almost like
they knew it was shitty and they're like
this is the bowie blow with the money
that you're paying movie yeah you
remember doing that movie all those kids
came in and started calling us nerds and
yelling yeah it's going garbage really
yeah Thank You Man and I are the only
dudes [ __ ] well there's one girl said
there's more of us that there are of you
which technically was true cuz they were
like 11 of us and like eight kids and
they said shut up [ __ ] white bread and
they start calling a white bread and
then the start throwing their mcdonalds
rises black it that said that it wasn't
a white kid I was like why practice
hater right either I or Kumail defendant
just got a this link maybe they'll go
away yeah I remember specifically
putting my Scully action figure in my
pocket that's appropriate oh no I eaten
is grown man holding it sugar let stand
by he's like they're gonna take Scully
haha nobody got abducted with a I used
to buy or how much worse of the Ray Rice
video hey did that happen into the
corner you saw a guy in a hello kitty
shirt just like not that much work I
think it'd be worse but yeah that boo
that movie was terrible absolutely awful
um I think I said it's like as bet it
was as bad as I mentioned the last
Indiana Jones as like one of the worst
things that oh well I me anna jones was
the same [ __ ] that was dosed up
period I was in New York for three years
and every summer we had like a crooner
would go see movies yeah and both of
those came at that time so the Dark
Knight but I always think of both of
those is like my one my worst like going
at midnight to see a [ __ ] new awesome
movie you know yeah I was real bad it
was so bad that night and that ending is
one of the worst things in the world I
heard you IND the end a [ __ ] whether go
well it's not they're not aliens it's
not a spaceship it's an interdimensional
ship right isn't that the whole I don't
know no
Hey oh no white bright hey guys this is
the kid yeah yeah nerd 20 what do you
mean it was an interdimensional ship
yeah well the base big twist in that
movie which I thought was so dumb was
that it's not aliens they're
interdimensional beings which you like
they're [ __ ] aliens who care till the
same thing yeah right if I was nothing
we made then that's a twist if it's some
crazy [ __ ] from out there that might be
aliens or interventional and all the
same thing oh I had no idea was
interdimensional they mention it in the
movie I just checked yeah it's like I'm
big it's like a big thing I kind of want
to see it again you know Steve abroad
yeah it's great well he said it's great
Tory behind the Steve O'Brien thing what
apparently Nate uh made fern old or
something go Brian very funny car I am
like Nate fern old um yeah from team
submarine very funny co need for an old
kept telling me Dan's burping yeah what
is it all don't worry about this year
who runs idea buddy rejecting air its
repelling water no no if we must die Mac
be a one does your last words right yeah
but Nate would they would be riding in
the night like this is a couple nights
in a row steve was like all right I'm
gonna go back home watch kingdom of the
Crystal Skull Nate's like why are you
doing that take a terrible movie goes I
know I just like it and then one day
they were I guess they were working
together and like Steve one of the
bathroom he left his notebook out there
and then Nate opened it up and it was
like a breakdown analysis of the kingdom
of especial skull and then Steve came
back look at me it's like what did you
guys good I just want to know why it
doesn't work over annals a it was just
like it he couldn't wrap his head around
why bad that's so interesting that's the
thing is that thing's gonna be bad in so
many ways usually they're good in like
similar ways like you have to have you
know there's like a real writing or a
good director or a good story yeah but
like even like you know like the
three-act structure and stuff would you
to deviate from but you have to be black
pretty [ __ ] good to not go by I just
watched was kind of
shitty out of the furnace out of I was
just getting it what's this it's a
Christian Bale and walk um woody arrows
woody harrelson and Casey Affleck Casey
Affleck went from like last years ago
year ago yeah I don't know about it but
the kid it was don't even bother seeing
it but it was like one of us the reason
I mentioned you mentioned three the
third three acting and they [ __ ] that up
left and right yeah it's hard to get
right I mean it'd make a great movie of
course to make a bad movie one thing has
to go around to make a great movie
everything has to be exactly right and
then you can make a bad movie that's so
much fun to watch or you can make it
just a boring bad movie most like what
bad movies are boring yeah yeah well
then we're good but rare I I thought
that glitter movie was gonna be like
spectacular bad like the mariah carey
coger manama so i started watching
glitter in it just it's just bad just
boring bad man it is boring bad people
watch that as a good day because mariah
carey's it that's the only reason it's
not good bed what's the one crossroads
that's the britney spears 10 that's
probably good they're the big save at
the end because she's breaking one of
her friends i did you have a joke about
it no she's a [ __ ] really respect her
works right yeah yeah you and Brittany
go way back but she's apparently the big
at the end of it whatever friends is
pregnant they don't know what to do
which weekend abortion should we keep it
and then she falls down a flight of
stairs don't lose the baby okay that's
the worst thing ever that's great oh my
god yeah that's pretty great I used to
watch as far as X Files goes when I was
that I used to be a doorman I don't know
if you knew that I was in that like
you're shocking if anyone I know Nicky
would be a doorman haha make sense yeah
hard to believe it I wasn't a professor
of women's studies before I started
doing comedy he's such a [ __ ] dick
see dan thinks that I'm a complete [ __ ]
oh you got there like a magazine last
month oh oh god you make that joke every
time no not like bikes here my kid I
have I made that one in front of you
yeah he said me exactly
right I was last time let me go Miette
nerd yeah I love it okay you're gonna do
your hey you know I get a sedan long
enough he'll he'll drop every literature
ever all the literature that he's
written right in the myth that was a
hard set inside yet you should read more
magazine sorry I read field and stream I
think oh right [ __ ] w da you [ __ ]
go watch much buzz wrong man [ __ ] so
bumpers it's drug med soap operas so you
were a doorman and you'd what I would
watch Xbox we had like we had a TV that
we snuck into the building and I would
watch x-files and work overnight to
watch x-files I'd actually get like
scared here's a grip this isn't great
scary episodes right oh yeah I've been
watching I'm season two now I'm just
watching i just finished season two
today yeah i watch the last episode and
it becomes the show we know so quickly
like by the end of like season 2 of X
Files ends with the one where he's in
the train car and they set it on fire no
the train car full of aliens that season
2 I thought of that is like coming in
much later that was much much later yeah
that show jumps the shark great hike
eight anyway season no fifth fifth and
sixth of good seven is going down and
then eight and nine a bed yeah when what
about when the lone gunman come into the
play lays it down there at first Cesar
in the first season Oh are they in the
first season that first season that was
that crazy way I don't know that much
about it but it was a spinoff i watch
the show and that's that first episode
is 911 they put 911 in the first yeah
there's the saris fly planes into the
twin tower it's crazy you see of the
longer than show yeah yeah and it's
before nine eleven on for 911 into the
Twin Towers yeah Wow or that that's what
they thought yeah holy [ __ ] so if only
where were they on in 2001 yeah that's
insane uh yeah it is pretty nuts that if
only they had listened the x-files then
we wouldn't have been nervous man that's
also like breaking boards on what or
they saw shadyside he saw that would be
hilarious in that game of the idea for
[ __ ] September 11 see all
what it was why I'm a huge a dennis
kucinich at that time anyone else I
don't get that but i'm sure i'm just an
idiot oh yeah i'm kidding relax no but
the vibrating bed does that to breaking
bed the very first episode right first
season and the first episode so much of
the stuff happens yeah like very first
episode he's already cooking Matheny
yeah isn't it the second episode where
they fall through the [ __ ] yeah
that's the top that's up top yeah or two
yeah that's crazy [ __ ] great yeah it
seems like that showed they were like
let's put him in the crazy situation and
then get them out of it cuz they were so
many times stuck in like the crazy [ __ ]
just unwinnable 6 i'm a winnable
situation one of the worst ones was that
was the Winnebago one when they're
magnets [ __ ] the mat well known in the
magnets whether in there right when
they're going to crush it and then
what's his name the cop DEA is outside
and they're inside then he calls and
protest hasn't pretend his wife's in the
house oh yeah that was the most fun
that's why we're like oh the how they
gonna get our this one oh yeah yeah well
I but to be fair like that show head
well I how many episodes were there like
60 or 70 total yeah probably yeah are
you X Files had helped me know like how
many more episodes good well they also
doing 25 a year and you know the the
writers kept changing so the first
duties are about the same than this
changed and vince gilligan comes in
season four season three I believe he
starts writing it but also mold I mean
duchovny laughed Scully said she only
wanted to be in half of him you know it
was a long time when was that by that
was like that's like six hih that's what
happens and they'll run an agent
Doggett's yeah the same thing happen I
thought huzhou whose dog it again one
cot t1000 a Robert Patrick yeah yeah I
did it just yeah he's great Robert
Patrick's great in the other lady who
was a Annabeth Gish who's your boy and
yeah she's like a sidekick ya know from
say anything how pissed off were the
other FBI agents who I wanna get
x-files that like they had like three
really experienced agents then there's
like just psyched like no I'm a member
of the team guys like when Ernie Hudson
joins Ghostbusters haha he just applies
for a job yeah but you think that so you
would say what what season wasn't that a
jump the shark then i would say season
seven is probably weaker than all of the
ones before it but not it is still
decent ones and then eight and nine
mostly pretty bad but i haven't decided
if I'm gonna watch through the whole cuz
my plan was just go through season 6 and
now I'm like I don't know maybe I don't
want to it's gonna be hard to watch it's
hard to when he gets bad it's hard to
watch i watch all the cheers doesn't get
bad it gets way worse by the end of it
but it's still good but it was way worse
it's still really good wash your times
too it's it's really touching in time
I'm really nostalgic like I got
emotional when i watch the beach when i
started watching and i realized that the
gang the opening is so nostalgic for me
because it was like right it was like
well as I would go to bed I would swatch
the opening of cheers oh like I'd have
to go to bed at that point and I don't
know for some reasons for those things
that you just took me a break he's
laughing he's that thing of it
everything I laughing hey I'm really not
gonna stop you don't get you don't
understand that you know what stop
yogurt no I was just laughing I just
think about the little fight you guys
had oh they have a 30 today and having a
young version of coach though yeah oh
yeah probably hun coach I am yeah
haven't you like you're like scrubbing
sochi's lounge what do you think you are
what do you think you are yet what do
you think you're Stephen Hawking I think
I'm the voice of a generation yeah I
remember like that all the time I
remember would be last time you did the
show you showed up dead sit you bein
just to deflate his blue a who's really
upset I was like why and he said it's
cuz there was a stripper that he was at
a strip club and he got like he fell in
love with the shrimp yeah anyway I
thought she was really into me she just
wanted a lap dance yeah yeah I know it's
all this trick it's not even a trick
that's
that's right then business plan it's the
dumbest thing I have left my wallet
there I've had that happen here but now
I've never fought in love as well never
never said the eurasia sure has
Impractical one they were in the youth I
never did you said that few thoughts
that she was really genuinely into you
and so you can I don't rub all that I do
recall and this is nothing I want to
talk about did you've done that before
too I feel like the last time I hung out
with you and Emily I made a complete ass
myself this is the one the last time I
smoked pot where I smoke pot with you
guys were we watching that a Vincent
Price movie and I got so stoned I
stopped talking to both of you have you
left well you doing with that and you do
remember me what you're saying I I don't
sense that I there i did a reparable
damage to our relationship I was so we
lied I lat and then cuz I kept thinking
about death you know like when you get
high sometimes you start thinking about
death I don't know I left yeah I kept
when I came back at a terrible way to
pitch that drug to anybody yeah a really
awesome drug were you think about dying
all the time yeah what is that nicotine
yes nicotine um but yeah I guess I do
remember that was it melt dad I think I
was doing the show yeah yeah you were
doing the show this was that maybe 3-4
months ago something yeah it was longer
than their heaviest thing you showed up
and you shud talked about a stripper
that you fell in love with oh this I
don't remember me fall in love with her
you said then thought I I think I know
what this is because you just mentioned
it the other day you said I don't know
every one girl that I thought she was in
probably the same girl it wasn't that it
wasn't that one though I feel that what
I just left my wife you remember that
stripper that I'm ya know I was pissed
off that time because L ace tribute to
the work I first off I quit strip clubs
like three months ago I haven't gone to
12 months i'm sorry i don't believe in a
horse yeah go ahead most people don't
have to do most people who never have to
take i quite clear man wide eyed boy
kissing I guess things there's like my
guess I haven't been in a while yeah
yeah yeah that's 10 sweet Norfolk that's
how normal people know they're not even
go I would happen the circle like five
times yeah yeah yeah Dan's like I quit
it I don't know I quit show clubs I
haven't gone in like the 22 min
well the thing is I paid extra for this
bad experience where you do you lie in
the bed and they're supposed to give you
a lap dance on the bed what all they do
is wait what that's a hooker no-no
that's a no-no but they just hover over
you on the bed what do you mean there's
like police know like they like they
want you down there like this is a lot
of bad experience but all they do is I
kind of hover over you like a go you
gotta tell us how much that was it was
is that the one that you told about the
hustler one no that was way more yes
like 220 but just have them kind of
sleep with you yeah wait so what do they
do then they just kind of grind on you a
little bit that's good it oh they're
like they steal your money but you get
to lie down for like one song I wouldn't
know I got 20 minutes half hour 20 days
he weighed 420 you should have been like
everything that's a ripple of you
shouldn't be like taking out your money
but I just put your money hovering over
her hand yeah that's [ __ ] I wouldn't
have done that what's the hustler story
ah we already talked about them well
tell me about that doors okay reason I
quit hey the reason anyway the reason I
quit strip clubs is uh I oh yeah Jesus
but anyway I was on that I went to a
strip club and I got married at the
strip club and I thought this is I was
an emotional time my wife a couple
months ago and I just started the girl I
the way she made it out would be was
that she was attracted to me I can't
even finish the story yeah and then yeah
you're that guy it's all right uh yeah
we went up to a private room when she
saw you did her pupils turn into dollar
signs I wonder where this torture yep
Jing Zhi yes 77 Watson Mariota yeah our
mounting my cash register that's right
her eyes are older than her mouth open
in about 20 fellow ya ba Hachi Hachi
machi ah ah so anyway I've stopped doing
Nestor clothes have I I told my show
Club story on here haven't I oh yeah
yeah its salt I think so I mean this is
just one of situations were instead of
that she's like this is how she got me
you know this is the last time I'll tell
the story I didn't
even tell it over the last deficit but
she's like first up she's like you want
coke and I'm like no I'm sober so you
went to a strip club you find the one
turquoise 0 here's the thing is i blame
the knitting factory because I didn't
know that there was no uh yeah animating
factories fall so I got there there's
nothing to do Hans labor day back up you
blame the Knitting Factory cuz there was
no Shelley like the way baby they knew
they made I rip it over the city cuz now
I gave up my place in New York place is
a very loose term and I commute from my
parents place when I'm in New York's I
commute in and I know that I saw that
there was a that there's no [ __ ] factory
shoka's was Labor Day and I waited nine
hours cuz it was Labor Day know many
clues dad I was supposed to meet up with
his girl like 11 right so I had I had
this time too I had some time to kill so
I went the hustler club and then I got a
text that the girl just to get real
horny and desperate for this day at
eleven that's a terrible idea get all
worked out yeah show my wedding together
rectify women and then you meet our
human being and there was no objective
akay I was objectified right I got in
there this girl comes out to me and she
says hey you want to go the private room
like how much does that and she's like
it's about 500 bucks why I can't afford
that she goes all right I'll get you the
semi-private room for 250 and then well
that's a steal yeah I'll get it for you
she's like hooking you up what a semi
wouldn't be exactly the haha right like
she's your friend who's an auto mechanic
yeah and then she are there other dudes
in there with you is that how it were
now it's like swivel chairs what it's
like it would you think you should have
took you to the offices yeah he was
really always there a computer was there
a desktop was there a printer there like
I'll be naughty office mate so anyway I
was like well yeah but I'm just gonna
leave with a boner she goes I'll take
care of you for an extra 300 bucks so
now it's 550 550 but she'll like [ __ ]
you or get you off should get me off
right so again up there and then she
says re we're gonna give me a
tip 2 right on top of all that yes I get
my sixth hour tip and then she already
gave her to give her six hundred bucks
so 600 bucks she starts giving me a hand
job and how well is your career going no
drink I was like a double dig some boxes
oh I know is it I'm not proud as is why
that's where Astra like a [ __ ]
PlayStation 4 yeah well I mean you know
i'm not a nerd fcz that's funny what you
guys think that this is his PlayStation
yeah this is my place I have really
never okay so anyway this is the work
this is the most insulting part of it
she first time she goes I don't normally
do this but you're really cute i love
the beard that was like that kind of
made for some reason that work cuz i was
getting in there Dennis food so then she
gives me it excuse me a handy ok ok ok
ok I'll wait so you go there you're
going to this room the semi-private room
what does the semi-private room look
like what is your buddies like a chair
like a booth like almost like a
telephone like a shirt like like a
lapdance blow the bigger ok and she gets
her Purell and she starts give me him
you're really cute white is she like
it's really geared here let me get this
anti-bacterial um so did you did she
give you a lap dance first as it just
like right down to the she uh yes she
she did it while smoking a cigarette no
she went right down to it she wanted
right down to it she started doing but
this is the most insulting part is that
she goes I want to see you finish
yourself off and she tried to make like
those hot but I think her hand was just
like I jerked off and that was the end
of it so you paid 550 dollars to the
jerk on yourself what's she helped with
him no star hundred and ten doc you
started yeah 610 dollars so so how long
was his whole experience uh it was about
20 minutes hahaha you're Liz no I'm I'm
it's funny biz why I've sworn it off and
everybody's a win there yeah and it's
also thing without you learned to let
you know you'll never do that again well
i was i get this i think it's awesome
huh no I hadn't
I haven't and I was kind of going on a
tear you know yeah yeah for a week I was
kind of going to tear with a couple
different places so that was like cuz
I'd quit I would you go alone yeah I
want the thing is I was starting to get
off on giving the money to the person so
that I realize I had a proud I get that
power thing yeah I got yeah it's like
that it becomes dirty when you give them
the money oh so I started getting turned
on by that yeah I'd like yeah I can't
understand this day don't want me yeah
this is really [ __ ] that I don't know
why they need this for the rent yeah pay
their children will be able to dinner
tonight yeah they look Timmy's not going
this is why I'm talking about sex
addiction problem I haven't I haven't
got back in two months you don't have a
sex addiction well the thing is another
thing that used to get me turned on was
like I would talk two escorts on the
phone like before I would jerk off and
just like I never got why I got one a
couple times but oh no I would negotiate
rates and that would turn me wait you
would like walk I get it totally you
would like to argue with them like a
come on 200 bucks when you're Jack I
would just be like hey what is it boy I
wasn't sure I feel like that would be
wrong yeah yeah yeah but then afterwards
I would think about it yeah sure go see
we just call him and be like this is
probably the most revealing podcast it's
pretty revealing yeah yeah yeah you
don't have to stop yeah i know i mean
we're not gonna edit it but yeah well i
don't want you to feel uncomfortable
they know it's fun um I'm after this
pocket I'm charging you six hundred
dollars yeah yeah yeah but the more I
hundred bucks to be the guest passes no
and I wasn't I was single during this
process me my girlfriend broken up and I
was just process process your you know
that's it wasn't how I get it I get it
where's the biggest tues how I got you
know I was still dating I wasn't like
yeah totally not just killing many were
doing stats and stuff right sets yeah
that's comedy so yeah yeah you didn't
like just go into a hole of like just
strip clubs yeah yeah yeah I mean that's
how it's only when you co can do just
disappear hey man it makes sense when
you don't I drink but if I didn't drink
I'd haven't drank since I've been out
here really yeah I had like one beer
maybe but you don't know what to do when
you're not drinking you're waiting to go
up it's like
you have time to kill it's like I don't
know anyway became a problem that's what
I'm try say so I stopped it like I did
so you stopped if you so whoever i'm
currently dating when this podcast i
just got the baby with no some clubs
where I can't i well I sex and that's my
early to mean I am I don't know I just I
don't do this anymore yeah I'm trying to
say well I was in my early 20 strip
clubs were like awesome and then when
you go to one you're like you freaked
out you know I don't go anymore Gazette
no but I'm saying once you get older
it's like it loses its its its novelty
after a while yeah you just become that
sad guy yeah but I'm everybody's been
there I mean I went to one in Atlantic
City where they didn't have a liquor
license some of them have it were they
don't look so you have to go down and
buy a six-pack and then you bring a
six-pack you have to say mug gifted
sneak it in no they let you just bring
it on your drink it it sounds like a
disaster for the stripper BYOB it's
probably it's probably a mess for them
yeah I'll get insanely shit-faced yeah
and then they just act like [ __ ]
yeah well we were we were nice young
boys when we came in there and acted
appropriately yeah exactly there's there
was one in in Springfield Boulevard in
Queens it was called the fickle Phillies
and it was just a ball cuz their horses
Phillies yeah it was right down belmont
it wasn't part of a ball one okay and
they all it was this what the stripper
part of it was this old lady who's
[ __ ] gross which would want they had
a clothesline with it with a curtain a
dirty curtain in front of it and she
would dance in front of the curtain and
then take a boom box out and put it in
front of her and just press play on the
boom box and dance in the bar like but
like naked it was the grossest thing you
would go because of how shitty it was
she like bullet holes in her ass like
show you like strip clubs oh I haven't
really been I've only been a couple
times I went dude Jumbo's clown room
this week I'm just clown room do you
know Jumbo's got strippers my part it's
not a strip club it's more burlesque um
I've only really been a couple times and
I've never hung out there one time we
want the last time we went we got this
was in Port under Seattle one of those
you know Portland it's like an art form
yeah yeah it is a Seattle you got kicked
out cuz one of the strippers got pissed
off and one of the guys what did he do
he didn't really do anything I won't
tell you who it is i'll tell you after
the podcast but i said with a bunch of
evil Kurt Braunohler yeah Emily was
there and
a bunch of people like a bunch of people
we all know somebody [ __ ] up well so I
hadn't really been this is about a year
ago and the guy was sort of telling me
like hey give him dollar whatever and
then he was like oh and then purell your
hands just as a bit but but she's
somehow heard from stage and then she
came down and to him and was like what
he put out his filthy here's your Purell
and she likes squirted Purell all over
him and walked away and then we just
would like I think this means we should
go like yeah we go and then got up and
left and then we just left also don't
get kicked out now but we putting my car
[ __ ] carved also like she is admitting
this it is dirty she had kerala yeah ya
did it be round yeah yes that's not you
guys yes no way you seem I gave your
[ __ ] together though as far as uh I mean
most things like yeah I've never heard a
coup male [ __ ] up story do you know what
I mean oh my when you were coming up in
Chicago though heavy well you can be the
day you called Bill Cosby a racist but
yeah yeah I remember that oh yeah what
do you guys think about that Hannibal I
know I think you did Howard Stern he
talked about it Oh what did he say he
was like you know you know Hannibal he
just like yeah it's weird man but it
happened good live with it it's fine
like he's like doesn't give any info
he's not like holy [ __ ] was nuts I said
it and and then all this [ __ ] no I mean
there hasn't get excitable like there is
a lot of I mean there's a lot of new
super there's like story supporting I'm
gonna know he did he's holding don't
matter i did research on it but here's
the thing he wasn't convicted I wasn't
convicted of rape no he paid them all
off he paid them more 13 of them and he
raided them all had the same story
roofies roofies yeah yeah they all had
the same story was 13 of them this
Turkey yeah he was just saying how you
know he goes he's never had anything
like that happening before his act where
it becomes like a media thing and he
goes I I researched it before I've been
talking about it for six months and it
was a bit that he'd been doing and then
someone put it on again somebody taped
and then and then Howard Stern was
trying to get basically out of them like
hey but isn't it weird that like you're
staying at a show and then you see it
like in an article the next day like it
becomes like news the next day is that
weird that the different dynamics of how
it comes across that way and he's
he agreed but he didn't like go into
detail about like I wish I didn't say it
or anything he was fine yeah I think
it's one of those things were like yeah
I said it but I want to keep going with
her yeah yeah pretty much but I you know
the guy did the research on it it's it's
[ __ ] I kind of like I mean leave on a
doing this for years right i mean
everyone i heard about that i just
didn't know well if it was even in the
nude wasn't it was in the news to kind
of recently about i would say maybe a
year and a half ago like it was coming
back up a little bit like I mean you
know he's got the best PR people in the
[ __ ] world yeah right yeah I think
it's a day control the media it is
anything but anyway and he's right it is
[ __ ] if you're gonna you're gonna
call young black comics to lecture them
and then you're going you're taking
advantage of you haven't raped anyone
make sure yeah you have to have a clean
slate of that what do you think that's
your controversial you should see my new
video what i say about Paula Poundstone
is gonna be all over this are discussing
their stories really gonna think you
yeah but now you've never had that you
kept it I've never had that either then
I ever had I've never had that either
bike if you want as far as well known
well yeah we're not famous yeah yeah
yeah no I can't gromek stories kind of
stories if I had a scandal in the
tabloids no no Bianchi's I did oh no
that was uh I tried to think of some
famous actor Oh for me you're saying L
from me oh yeah it's gonna think of mad
about you get whatsapp all right I don't
think but wait when you were like I
always wonder what we were like before
you met Emily with women r you gonna
commit or no not really I wasn't bad but
I wasn't i was i right pretty shy yeah
pretty shy pretty shy so his Alicia I
have ever been but yeah pretty shy I was
never like really great but I would date
girls for a little bit and then be
single and date like I wasn't yeah
comedy made you more confident right
coming yeah it also yes a hundred
percent in Chicago there was no like you
know people now get laid at shows and
stuff in Chicago that was not a thing
really you could do it there weren't
like girls who would come to shows ready
well when I was in Chicago doing comedy
wasn't like cool or hip stand-up was not
cooler over there I then moved in I was
like oh like actually cool people kind
of come to shows there was like a random
like old people and stuff
was not it yeah it was funny comics but
there were no shows that were like cool
shows really i mean lincoln lodge was
okay no not really do you have any uh
like when you got up like what was your
act like when you first i was one of
this what was the War like what was the
dumbest move you made on stage and you
first started i wouldn't i try to do
Hedberg one i remember i used to wear
sunglasses and [ __ ] he's a puppet used
to pump you had a puppet show thing oh
you dad we have puppets yeah you
remember that the x-files david duchovny
in it yeah what was this remind me more
forget it was about my breakup one of my
many breaks i did that i didn't reenact
the breakup with puppets Wow actually
whether there's one table tape of it on
my myspace page oh is that I've left up
yeah just use yours really exist what's
that one to archive thank you maniac is
next for his fans does he is he is that
before yeah yeah tons of times he wants
to get t-shirt and have the Hulkamania
yeah what I get like a montage of like
people who really look hard up wearing
the century yeah really hard I just like
a diner waitress and home no one
happened sometimes i'm thinking i'm
making headway for him not to [ __ ] do
that anymore and then [ __ ] happens like
the other night we talked about this a
couple yeah I have no fans obviously
well yeah every once in a while somebody
will recognize you for southern it'll be
in pretty Sean yeah it's the greatest
thing yeah but have any other night of
parking lot these girls like hi dad and
they just like giggle and go by in their
car and then he's like we would ran at
him but I but is credit to me on that
point where it's like a psycho thank you
I'm strolling barista hey can I put this
in you let me guess that would
uh-huh but you didn't you didn't ask
them for the number that i was actually
good you got approached a lot huh um I
mean I mean not a lot but I'm ready yeah
pretty often and more actually outside
of LA cuz i think here people no not a
no New York does that to nobody and
nobody says anything but it happens like
I would Silicon Valley was airing it was
like all the time it was like pretty
much every day a lot even when I would
travel and stuff it would happen a lot
and now it happens and meltdown like did
it it happens probably if I'm out like
every day but not like but it also
depends on where you are well if you go
to the Grove yeah I don't ever go to the
Grove yeah like you got your like on
purpose I just did so far from me oh I
don't like of the growth I don't ever
avoid I like the grove wood ranch grill
i like i like the grove i love it
there's a singaporean place and the
farmers market I won't eat that but then
why because I'm i don't remember like a
hamburger yeah rice kinda guy yea yea
you know you used to be a doorman you
said that's so aggressive yeah you dare
coin out of your carriage Norman [ __ ]
doorman doorman huh but yet I do like to
grow right I don't have a avoid places
cuz of it oh ok ok that's what I was
wondering well Rob seems everything is
like dumbest move you've made on stage
like when you were starting well I used
to be very different like I wouldn't
take the mic out of the stand I would do
one liners how I want you to hurry and
you were also very um more low-key way
low key right yeah like sort of play up
the nervousness I had a very specific
like delivery it was like really man I
understanding Woody Allen yeah I was
like a Pakistani buddy else it was what
it was actually more like a Pakistani
Jake Johansen okay which is actually he
was posted or show yesterday but uh he
barely got to know how do you guys know
next one hour don't reducer knows him
yeah he's awesome yeah he scraped so
funny nice guy too yeah great guy great
guy love to have you back shake
we love you we love you so much keep the
light on for you uh-huh but you also do
you think this is gonna screw up like
that story about the strippers a scrub
can be getting a girl riggan I think the
assumption that they're listening to
your podcast no it's happened before cuz
it what happened what do you mean well
I've had like I was all day google i/o
yeah they Google and then this girl that
I'm I may be meeting in next month in
Vancouver uh you have a date set up yeah
I kind of you probably know her but uh
who I'll tell you I guess but uh but
yeah she was like I just listened your
podcast you're not sometimes you don't
seem like the guy you're presenting oh
really oh she said that yeah well then
go ahead and say that but I've had
people like that's the thing like oh
that's interesting not her specifically
but this is the one before this where
she's like these different to hear that
side of you with all the sex and drugs
you've done not gonna hearing their
voice or it's like oh wait santa's beard
is coming on Wistia knows what I believe
not true yeah I'm a little nervous now
that I you know that was well you just
don't say the shadow you say you know I
guess well that would be honest though
it was months ago I want to make this
point from now so by the time his heirs
will be I for five months you realize
there's tons of should I haven't said
about myself on this by no but my god
that's you don't have the guy who's
you're the guy who left hahaha hey you
don't got heavy waiting out no no your
just your blood on your joking blurter
John will tell me like the most innocent
shitty goes I went to a doctor's
appointment the other day don't mention
on the podcast are you Tony Soprano do
you think you need to burn this image or
toughness that's not true yeah you had
where the Dodgers that is not Joe what's
that you're the doctor yeah he don't get
how like tell me seven wins oh my my
Scully action that we had where he's
like he's like oh it was something like
aw us I skipped out on something don't
say that on the podcast and then on the
episode we talked about me [ __ ] girl
mentor having a heroin overdose
no it was like holding can you say
something Sean only one any missed an
appointment those invisible was it was
nicely i don't know i can say it skipped
out given where I can't I don't know if
I could say it okay wait so this comes
up oh yeah oh you mean therapy yeah the
fact that you go to a third know you can
set to you forever yeah yeah it's true
yeah sure I and that was Tony Soprano
only other person I know who's afraid of
talking about having a therapist was
Tony [ __ ] see ya know that's why how
you know the therapies work yeah yes
start a gang yeah yeah I'm gonna be more
by the time but give it a little more
time and I'll be able to be more honest
in this podcast wait so this comes out
months from now yeah have you know well
you might be it might be moved up with
ya why we are like a long why'd you need
to reach 30 people gonna line we're
gonna give yours a big poo yeah you're
there to help is vodka a tweet about it
yeah oh yeah we gotta burn your eyes
like this is us landing LeBron gee
that's some rough ones Camille oh yeah
oh yeah we have a bunch of them backlog
we have you have a bunch of us cuz we
live in LA New York in LA so you live
here i will move your two months ago oh
I didn't know that I hang out here now
we should hang out sometime mm-hmm um
but I sure I start working this week but
but after everything long as I go for
till februari okay it's a long one bite
wait it just let me know when you were
you free whatever I can love about this
because this is I'm sure relatable to
all you guys is like well not the
listeners but you to maybe some of this
huh it's like for me if I don't have
like work so like I was working in
September but I have an off October
waiting to do this like I never know
what I should be working on yeah I feel
guilty if i don't do anything so me i
should watch the next files and then cuz
that's kind of agenda and that becomes
work like you said yeah yeah it is work
it is work so so so I like I'm liking
that we start Silicon Valley because
then I'll have one thing and I can just
focus on that yeah and then not feel
guilty about laying around the other
time and for me the greatest feeling is
like so I start you know are usually
going at about 6am sometimes I'm only
being like the first scene of the day
and i'm done at nine yeah but or even if
you're you know shooting more that's the
best fitting easy but looking it's like
9am and you've already shot a scene
that's the [ __ ] bad none I would be
asleep yeah yeah the greatest days of
the ones where you shoot early morning
and you're done by like noon or one and
then you have the rest of the day and
you like how about the next is there
five days a week or is it they shoot
five days a week but you're not in it
I'm not in it you know if i'm not in the
scene that i'm not there but like this
one so for I saw the schedule for the
first two weeks I mean I'm in like three
four days a week no more like four days
it's awesome Morgan's role in that room
yeah most and what half the scenes of
them yeah well we're cheers bar yeah
yeah yeah it totally is our cheers bar I
totally is our cheers bar and then this
this season the structure the first few
episodes a little different cuz that
actor passed away yeah dad he was
awesome 800 the best guy this is the
thing whenever we do Q&A men if he
wasn't anybody nowadays now that's the
thing yeah there should be like
everybody does something whenever I read
about people who got Ebola they're like
they were the kindest like why is it
only infecting was a [ __ ] but yeah
right i mean she shouldn't get a boy
about a couple of [ __ ] yeah she
called the cops on my party but a q and
A's people would always ask me hey what
about that guy like I don't know he's
not gonna be on the show anymore what
yeah I was what do you want us to tell
you yeah yeah yeah he's he passed away
how are you gonna deal with it well by
having him not act on the show we're
gonna have a hologram Andy Serkis outfit
acting huh hi I randomly he'd been
living in his house for six months
anyway studying him yeah yeah why would
ya people people people just not even
real age when I asked you here when I
hear you say oh well he pet they were
here you say passed away again that's
all I want to hear he's a date I think
they also want to show that they know
about the show and stuff you know but oh
right right so there's gonna be you know
if the stretch is different cuz he's
gone um so they got to figure out you
know how to how do all right let the
storyline has to look I've read the
first six out of the ten super funny
super funny show yeah it's this is gonna
be a [ __ ] greats like you're gonna try
to go know that show that I work on is
so shitty yeah we're really asking me
hardball oh yeah hahaha you like common
is the weather in LA it's pretty good
huh I wanted to do I'm gonna try I'm
watching lost again I wanted to do a
lost podcast and then some time there is
there is a lost pot there's a video of
them a few of them when they revisit it
and but I wasn't listen to one of them
that back the animal that's really
shitty what's it called back to the
island there's a 10 who we have our
first like podcasts rivalry with a
podcast with that package I oh yeah oh
yeah they're right right yeah [ __ ] you
guys why is it shitty why is it shitty I
listened to what I was super boring one
does too I don't know the barely tone of
the show there's two guys that are like
video game guys think they work for like
one of the vegan websites or something
like different ones and then they're
doing a lost one I forget what that what
that one came out around the same time
as X valves do we started around the
same time yeah that would hear them
mention in the same X Files yeah yeah
and they're good I don't know I would
listen people seem to like that one but
I haven't I haven't listened to it did
you watch lost it was on yes we will be
talking about a month yeah um this is a
every like month and a half I'll get a
text from Sean or like an email like hey
did you see this video and it's like
some [ __ ] light in the sky well
here's the thing i know because i know
you like that side you love that I love
that I like the [ __ ] thing that looks
like this legs walking have you seen
that no it's like ice in philly a [ __ ] i
can't from him I can't believe I don't
it's what is it it's been photographed
it's been recorded three times in the
same town and it's the [ __ ] craziest
looking thing it looks like it's just
legs walking like wobbly Lewis blocker
that's good yeah yeah wow I was dead-on
I was very timely you gotta be for the
last podcast with calista flockhart snap
bracelets oh yeah I man see ya you gonna
take down the PEC pet rock so is it on
the grounders in the sky no it's on the
ground but you're into that [ __ ] dude
like we were into the Montauk Monster
yeah mods are months they never figured
that out it's the body's gonna be 0
it was a dog no the body disappeared
well they kept moving people's backyards
it's right near there's a there's a
there's a animal testing plan right yeah
right near long island long island hey
what do you mean they kept of people's
backs you ever found it one guy I read a
whole article with it like that they
moved to this one guy's backyard and
then we like pranking him know when the
heat started no no he was like keeping
it for them and then when the heat
started they moved it somewhere else
there when people to find it and they
like kept on movie ever found it kept
moving it and then I think he
disappeared but they people who do the
pictures and they're like it's a dog the
dogs it's a dog skeleton and so it's a
dog that's been a pickled dog basically
it's been in salt water for like however
long okay a dead dog you know right
there is there really is an island off
of lon that does experiments yeah and
does animal experiments yeah I've seen
some videos of the pictures of those who
it's like that is the most brutal
[ __ ] thing I've ever seen in my
entire I saw a lab picture of a Labrador
were testing on cats and it was one of
the worst things I've ever [ __ ] it's
awful and it's really awful what did i
do but it's just like them putting funny
hats on yeah I got one was dressed as a
businessman what's the legs one the legs
when I [ __ ] it was a creature that just
looks like less i got creature that's
walking and day you know they have a
name for it then name for everything but
it looks just like legs and it looks
like it's kind of like like you know the
glow-in-the-dark kind of green it's a
little like that is it underwater no
it's on land it's [ __ ] crazy never
calling they just video but there's
three videos of it not the same thing
around the same area and philly though
it's just an Eagles fan yeah it just
sounds like a slender man sorry internet
oh it's it's it's not Phillies um the
Green Man is philly yeah you know the
Green Man no yeah that's the guy who's
like yeah that's the wrong guy huh yeah
that's always sunny thing yeah always
sunny sort of did a riff on it when they
had a guy in all green but the green man
was a real guy in some like suburb of
philly who was horribly wide was it
horribly what a horrible thing for me to
say it just feels like very deformed and
blind he was a monster
what'd he do but he was just a guy that
lived there and he would at in the
middle of the night because he couldn't
leave during the day he would go on
walks by the highway and people start
calling him the green man I don't know
why oh okay but I existed he's a real
guy and he died but that's what the
Green Man Philly things started but this
was like I get [ __ ] here I'm gonna get
my phone and look it up you guys talk
for a second cuz it yeah it's a cool
thing Emily told me about it and I don't
think I'll show Stephanie we've you look
back and we're just like shut down look
at each other's we're sleeping each
other's shoulder yeah there's that I
think every town has a thing like that
did you have that in your town watch
jersey devil well not really the Jersey
Devil but also we had let this lady the
paint lady we had the pink lady a pound
for pound ridge New York yeah we had a
real thing we had the pink lady which
was this lady who would walk just out of
nowhere would just walk the streets like
[ __ ] like it was like 1940s pink dress
and she was like 80 years old creepy I'm
one day she was really creepy and one
day she got a pizza place just there by
herself and talk to herself and then one
day she wrote on a napkin I have a I
have a million dollars in my basement
and it's possessed by the devil so these
two dudes and I new truck broke into her
basement and there was nothing King is
don't believe her she also thinks it's
devilish yeah yeah oh you see a million
if you notice choosing to believe half
of that then we had pockets we had sky
pockets were walking on his pockets out
of his thing and he was just a mentally
handicapped well there's a guy there's a
leather man and pan origines was another
man well he was turn of the century but
he used to just like he lived in the
reservation in the woods and he would
just wear thick leathers and people
would give him food and he wouldn't make
it and the boys started he set up a
shack in the woods because the boys in
town would throw rocks at him oh really
oh yeah he was just kind of a [ __ ]
person I guess yeah that's right that's
what that's for having that was mostly
like back in the direct the Jersey Devil
just and then somebody with Down
syndrome yeah they'd know had a clan and
they were fine with there's nobody knew
had to put them in the silence they
didn't know how to do I was like
remember that kid that stole that kid
was great the kid that stole all the
planes the feral kid that would live in
the woods he will in the woods and Rob
people's houses and then he stole like
six planes and then we just fly them and
you know how to land oh just crap
he's like million-dollar planes like you
know excited about oh you just babe I
guess he just would he knew how to land
enough that he could get out but he and
then he was there we just had these
crash planes out of nowhere and then he
i think he ended up did he get arrested
right Mike did yeah he got arrested but
for like dude for a long time he was on
the run and then he did but he knew how
to living like the deep woods you're
like live in trees and [ __ ] he's like
our Johnny Appleseed yeah pretty much
let people know lessons to win this
whole when everything crumbles you know
those people what everybody be left
don't have the people that are gonna oh
yeah you know I don't I would know I
could make survive in the woods for an
hour I don't know six hours
realistically well how long you think
you can survive in the woods for a week
you really feel really with nothing
you're given nothing yes I think it
would find a way for a week yes so
you're gonna you you would kill animals
you have you done it before no but not
exactly I wouldn't know I've really
thought about how I do it you'd have to
get hungry enough to [ __ ] do it well
I already thought I area how would you
what's your plan well I've seen a lot of
videos where they jump on the deer from
the trees haha of course of course
that's your [ __ ] plan they jump on
the deer from the tree was in a bed
that's a bad plan there's an awful plant
a deer that way no yeah that's how you
get him oh yeah you could jump I'm just
saying like a better surprise party for
the deer well yeah I'll cover myself in
thick brush and then I jump off the
branch and I grabbed it by its net and
as I'm swinging down i crack its neck
the way to do is booby traps you just
put booby traps you came back with a
muscley illogical and so that you're
incapable of doing I could not do how
could you do a boot you can't set up
[ __ ] in your apartment your one bedroom
apartment IG's yeah I have my wife set
up booby traps in the woods she why she
knows long gone she has told my wife
runners magazines yeah she be gone so
she would you be able to run from all
the Predators she'd be like with a woman
you know shoot a ruby baby what the [ __ ]
she now I'm going to my family wait your
fans about my wife being with a woman
what you really are honest on this
pumpkin yeah that one's that good the
woman was to court louder I can't find
this [ __ ] [ __ ] okay legs thing will
put the link up on the podcast I'm gonna
look at that bastard we're done I tell
you know I just wanted I just want to
add this before we end I I went through
a breakup in April and I went through my
god I'm not gonna go through this
anymore i'm just saying that every day I
watched a conspiracy theory video I went
through the Illuminati hahaha Charles
that is the craziest big breakup that's
perfect right I dealt with the proud
he'd watch out big rank whatever up i
read the Franklin Franklin cover up
what's the one what's the island looked
at that I love red i watch the video on
Matt the island none that I send you a
resort whatever the resort is thanking
cover up the guys who goes great credit
Oh Bohemian Grove Bohemian Grove got a
real was a real thing I got obsessed
with MK ULTRA last podcast I know I'm k
else was real yeah MK else is real yeah
Nazi [ __ ] that's a proven one there's
also there was the Kennedy assassination
one wasn't real but there's a there's
one around the Kennedy round there's
another Kennedy um was the Gulf of
Tonkin what was it there was a well it
was a [ __ ] let me set false flag was the
first part unless in crisis no they set
up a false flag operation which was the
UH it was this it was what the Bay of
Pigs was based on and I'm not getting
what that is yeah it's crazy I had a lot
of time alone I was on the road a lot
yes that's why I send you that I sent
you that no I love it I love it I love
it I was just I know I know I know I
know I don't know I guess I love it man
I when I think something's get real I
believe stuff I believe we get wrong
time I believe in dick so what so yeah
we still believe witches and [ __ ] right
I really like Bigfoot I was like so
psyched I'm doing it was real I got
excited when they figured out who the
[ __ ] Jack the Ripper was and yes that
was for is that enough real that size
right wow that guy just Walt the genetic
test run look I sent you that one too oh
no I didn't send you that I didn't but I
looked up all about that guy the
kozminski guy whatever the barber yeah
and then yesterday I write a thing that
there were like four different genetic
scientists people looked at and were
like what he did the test wrong and then
he was like yep I [ __ ] up the test and
the way he'd done the test basically
anything would have been a match
so there really isn't you know [ __ ] the
internet because it's all based on
people's books coming out they make it
seem like it's wrong oh yeah do that
last guy the Zodiac zodiac that same
[ __ ] and that was booked oh did you and
it's all [ __ ] right that was like
Kennedy assassination had that for years
even before the Internet where it was
like I read so many Kennedy
assassination books and a lot of them
were [ __ ] a lot of only a couple in
the head like facts in them and stuff
like that and then you watch once
veteran alex jones show now no I like
this stuff I learn you and you watch one
special by Peter Jennings and then he
just debunks all the [ __ ] [ __ ] that
you read for 20 years yeah the jury did
you ever watch that spent that Kennedy
we're gonna can't the kennedy wanna know
i mean a little bit i know about that
stuff a little bit i'm more into the
supernatural a little bit more like
cryptozoology i love but i love like all
those crazy experiment [ __ ] i love Dave
even they've admitted that there's
there's that there's species of animals
that we have anything well sure yeah but
you know they found a new monkey five
years ago that's not that exciting
though that's kind of cool but is it
wise I mean I'll it's slightly different
from the other monkey's it's like cool
yeah it's like genetically just another
species but it looks like your average
man well it looks like some kind one
showed it to you like that's a monkey
that's some kind of monkey yeah it's
still kind of an [ __ ] yeah it was
little it was very little but you know
they've seen little monkeys but this is
the best thing is whenever there's a
tidal wave that's not the best thing by
me whenever there's like a tsunami but I
mean and then the the [ __ ] the ocean
basically goes inside out and all the
creatures from like past the light yeah
all looked just like all of God's rough
drafts for it's so cool they're all
prehistoric they're all cool again yeah
they're all the ocean is where all the
great [ __ ] yeah that was like you watch
that video where it was a there was the
thing that they didn't know what it was
for like a week it was that they have
they found out this thing that just ate
a great a great white shark or even what
do they think what they thought and
thought it they didn't know what it was
but they're like there's some creature
that's eating sharks they had it it was
a shark it was a even bigger shark it
was this insanely big shot wasn't true
that is the least interesting answer I
know it is you're just like but it was a
real thing for Anna whale shark then not
a whale shark it was like bigger I think
I'm gonna go
I don't know that mega went on that
thing was [ __ ] be able to movie man
ya know he hit he listen you're talking
about now I'm not it was a real thing it
was all I like to thank Donnelly's just
watching terrible sci-fi lady it was
right as in a sharknado who's right
after the shark night hahahaha you can't
tell me that was fake yeah yeah yeah
well I'm yeah I don't think that that
was real that's what I'm saying uh it
wasn't think it was that they had that
was I think promotion for Megalodon no
it was I know if used by the side by was
Dean Cain giving you the best yeah is
deep getting now assigned to dr. sure Bo
please hahaha well before we go is there
like one dumb story from your childhood
something were you just a horrible
mistake you make this kind of demon a
really good conversation about well I
know that but I'm trying to you know uh
can you tell us why you go to
bodybuilders gym because he's got a nice
body shots a worse name for a gym it is
Barry mom-and-pop gay it's a gay gym i
miss you i should erase that remember
you can have your fans tell me where you
go Jim um huh well the good thing is
that we have the chilling pause I think
it's fine I don't think I happy girl
stock well you let us know thank you um
I grown up in Pakistan yeah don't tell
me you're afraid of dogs a dumb story
yeah yeah that sounds like a dumb [ __ ]
day yeah I think of like a you know like
you know lumen ating yeah our audience I
um i'll say i like it marin went to
junior college dropout um yeah we well
because we have a lot of most people
didn't have dogs like as pets cuz i
think some people believe in Islam that
if you have a dog spirit like angels
don't come to your house oh really we
just we didn't have my house was full of
angels the story checks out but we had a
lot of stray dogs around and that was
also like part of like you know why I
thought all dogs were [ __ ] we
wouldn't be will get chased by dogs and
stuff you see [ __ ]
with like skin missing from their face
Oh ruling at the mouth until we just
[ __ ] start chasing you and you just
had to run better like you're like 10
years old yeah you're 10 and you'd hear
stories of like oh this kid got bit by a
dog and he had to have 10 10 injections
step in his atten- car and its stomach
that's how it used to be for rabies cuz
you know look this up right the disease
that as a highest rate of fatality is
rabies rabies is it's literally it has a
radio lab I believe it's called blood
radiolab is this podcast a total korea
was great yeah it's great i think it's
called blood or whatever the one with
rabies is it's a little [ __ ] virus or
whatever it is it literally crawls up
your spine like it like works its way up
your spine gets into the brain it makes
you insane and it makes you insane what
it does is it's so amazing it's like a
horror movie thing because it makes you
aggressive because it's spread through
the saliva so it makes you aggressive so
you bite other people so you can spread
it more so that's how [ __ ] genius
this little thing is a baby nobody hobby
yeah nope yeah and like almost nobody
survives and now there's like new
theories of like maybe if you do a blood
transfusion there's one tribe like in
Peru or something there's a group of
people that are immune to it so they're
trying to figure out what their army
into it so it's a [ __ ] scary thing
you know you got a cat arrived it was
like don't be a [ __ ] bro yeah I could
ever yeah you go there all the whole
tribe is insane and biting each other
you're like oh they're not it you're not
immune they just think this is our
humanity oh wow that's not well dude
thanks so much for duo dude friend thank
you really yeah it was just so much fun
of moms Silicon Valley will come back
why won't you well no I just thinking
like yeah you know probably you know
like I was just thinking promote like
we're gonna have a good oh yeah oh no no
that's fine yeah what do you improve oh
just a second i will come back in april
but you know you can watch the old ones
on itunes or HBO go and your twitter and
you have your x-files files FML nkumai
ln i also do a video game podcast with
my wife Emily Gordon that's called the
indoor kids that son Nerdist and oh the
meltdown with Jonah and Kumail is a
stand-up series that we did
for Comedy Central that I hosted by
Jonah ray yeah and that's you can buy
that also on itunes and i believe you
can see it on the Comedy Central app
Comedy Central app for free so that's
out there on amazon or something cool
thanks again I really appreciate having
me talk to yourself a good one I like
thanks for listening to the my dumb
friends podcast to see our hosts
performing live this week here are some
dates for you dan st. germain is up in
San Francisco doing the SF sketchfest
starting tonight Wednesday februari
fourth he's doing the 8pm tabernacle
show at the darkroom on Mission Street
tomorrow februari fifth that's thursday
at 8pm dan is co-headlining the punch
line with the lovely Arden myrin for
more info on the shows go to SF
sketchfest calm and please san francisco
friends go out and see dan see him in
person tell him you're a friend of the
podcast then Dan heads back to Los
Angeles for a show friday night and this
is very funny fitness size fitness sighs
its comedy in a yoga studio so that's
Friday februari sixth at siesta yoga at
18 25 north western avenue in LA and
then monday dan is on the venerable hot
tub show at the Virgil it's on Santa
Monica Boulevard that's februari ninth
Monday februari knife the hot tub show
at the Virgil those tend to sell out so
get your tickets in advance if you're
going to try to see him in Los Angeles
you can see our good friend Sean
Donnelly performing this week at Rick
Bronson's house of comedy in phoenix
arizona from wednesday februari forth
through Sunday februari 8th see him
there for more of Sean's upcoming dates
go to Sean Donnelly comedy com and of
course for more info on dan st. germain
states as well as a link to his album go
to dan st. germain net yours truly
thomas attila lewis producer of the
podcast hey you can see me at proctors
theatre in schenectady in the GE theatre
space hosting aquafina the comedy rap
sensation from MTV's girl code
she's coming out to do a show that's
this Saturday februari seventh at
proctors theatre and schenectady for
more info you can go to proctors theatre
org go to Tom com quick shout-out to
everybody who has been kind enough to go
write a review at iTunes over the past
month thank you so much so like to thank
Dean eels and who else do we have here d
Neil's spoken of stance do and boom
boomerang for giving us some good
reviews we could use some more please go
to your iTunes and to do a quick rating
just click on the stars and write one
sentence some of these are just about
five words long it doesn't take much so
thank you for doing that write us a
letter at my dumb friends podcast to
gmail tweet us please follow us on
Twitter please at dumb friends cast on
Twitter and this next time around our
next recordings are going to be in March
and we'll be posting photos and that
kind of stuff at our Facebook page so
just look for my dumb friends on
Facebook and you'll find our page thanks
again and have a great week
the my dumb friends podcast is part of
the all things comedy network for other
cool podcasts go to all things comedy
com our opening and closing song is
called Mary the boxer by Phil Pickens
you can find out more about Phil Phil
Pickens com
lift me up lift me up lift me